if you have student loans the 2020
election could have a big effect on how
you manage what you owe
that's because donald trump and joe
biden have quite
different approaches to student loan
policy so
let's dive in to what the two candidates
propose and how that could affect you
joe biden has put forth a pretty
comprehensive student loan policy plan
which tweaks the programs that are
currently available to borrowers
the most important proposal that biden
has put forth
is limiting student loan payments for
those who make
under 25 000 per year so he's suggesting
that any federal student loan borrower
who makes
under 25 000 a year won't have to make
any student loan payments at all and if
you make more than 25 000
you'll pay five percent of your
discretionary income per month
after the first 25 000 is taken under
consideration
then all borrowers will also be eligible
for student loan forgiveness
after 20 years of payments and that will
be tax-free
that's a big change from what's
currently available to student loan
borrowers
right now borrowers have the option of
several different payment plans that
could be tied to your income or not you
could pay 10
of your income 15 of your income you
could pay over
10 years or longer biden's proposal
would simplify
student loan repayment and it would make
it so that everyone
ends up on the same plan automatically
but it would be possible to opt out if
you want to
another change that biden is suggesting
is updating the public service loan
forgiveness program
that's a program that's available to
borrowers who work for non-profits or
the government
and they can repay their loans over a
10-year period
and then get forgiveness tax-free at the
end
now what biden is suggesting is
simplifying this program
broadening the types of federal student
loans that are
available to be repaid under the program
and that will hopefully make it more
possible for more people to take
advantage of it
biden also proposes creating a new
forgiveness program
that would allow for ten thousand
dollars in forgiveness
for public service workers and would
allow for incremental forgiveness over
five years
instead of one big forgiveness amount
after
those 120 payments as is currently
allowed
but the campaign hasn't released a lot
of details
about how the current public service
loan forgiveness program
and this new program would interact
one other change that biden is
suggesting is putting forth
more protections for private student
loan borrowers
everything we've talked about so far
only relates to federal student loans
and about 10 percent of students with
loans
currently in repayment have private
loans from
banks or credit unions or online lenders
and they generally don't get the benefit
of as many
consumer protections so biden's campaign
says that he
will provide more protections for
private loan borrowers
and that he will make it more possible
for them to get their loans discharged
in bankruptcy
which right now is very difficult to do
donald trump's student loan plans were
put forth
in his 2021 budget proposal to congress
now these are proposals that you can
view as his
best case scenario for student loan
policy but
it's unlikely that all of these will
actually
be made into law anytime too soon
because they will require negotiation
with congress and legislation in order
for them to actually
happen but these different policies can
give us an idea
of how donald trump views student loans
and what you could
see happen if he wins in november the
first policy change that he's suggesting
is limiting student loan borrowing for
graduate students
and parents who participate in the plus
federal loan program
right now there isn't a cap on the
amount
of plus loans you can borrow essentially
you can borrow
up to the cost of attendance at a
college minus
any financial aid you've received
separately
that means that borrowers such as
graduate students and parents
can end up taking out a lot more student
loans than they could potentially
afford trump has suggested limiting plus
borrowing to
100 000 over the course of a student's
education for parents
and limiting it to 26 500
for graduate students in total that
would be a big change and could
potentially help borrowers from taking
out
more loans than they can safely manage
another suggestion of trump's is
consolidating and simplifying the income
driven repayment plan
program this is also something that
biden has been looking at and of course
he
suggested putting forth one program for
everyone that would be income driven
trump's suggestion
is simplifying all the income-driven
plans that currently exist
into one that limits payments to 12.5
percent of discretionary income
per month another thing that's different
about trump's and biden's
income-driven repayment plan proposals
is that trump suggests
all borrowers who have undergraduate
student loans
should repay them over a 15-year period
whereas any borrowers with
any graduate student loans would repay
them over a 30-year period
trump has also suggested eliminating the
subsidized
federal direct loan program
the way that federal direct loans work
is there are two different types there's
unsubsidized loans and subsidized loans
subsidized loans are similar to
unsubsidized
that they come with an interest rate
that you are supplied with when you
first borrow the loan
but students don't have to pay the
interest in certain periods and the
federal government
actually subsidizes the interest that
accrues when a student is
in school when they're in their grace
period after graduating
and when they're in a period of
deferment when they have postponed their
loans for a number of reasons
trump has said that it's possible and we
should
eliminate this program because some of
the other changes that he suggested
such as simplifying income-driven
repayment
would be sufficient and fair now this
could
affect the students with the most
financial need because those are the
ones who qualify
for subsidized loans and it means that
they would end up paying the interest
during more
periods of repayment and essentially
paying more interest
overall on their student loans trump has
also suggested
eliminating the public service loan
forgiveness program
now that's the program that allows for
repayment
over 120 months to a
borrower who works in public service
such as a nonprofit
or the government and allows for tax
free forgiveness
after that 120 month period is over
trump has also said
that this program potentially unfairly
allows for public service workers to get
more benefits for their student loans
compared to those who go into
the private sector so what's important
for borrowers to know about this
potential change
is that it would only affect borrowers
who
are starting out with their student
loans in the year
that this change goes into effect that
means if you're somebody who has been
repaying your loans planning to get
forgiveness
according to public service loan
forgiveness in say three or four years
if in 2021 this program is eliminated
you would likely be as they say
grandfathered in
meaning you could still get forgiveness
based on the amount of time that you've
already been repaying your loans at the
end of that 10-year period
and you would still have access to the
program that you've been planning to
have access to
all this time if the program is
eliminated
students who borrow loans for the first
time starting that year
would not have this program to look
forward to would not be able to
pay their loans with the understanding
that they can get forgiveness in the
future
so that's a big change but it would only
affect those
in the future based on what we know now
about the conversations on this program
now it's important to know that of
course all of these are proposals
and we don't necessarily know which will
come into law
and of course this all depends on who is
elected in november
but it's important as a student loan
borrower to know
what's out there as a proposal know how
your loans could be affected by who wins
in november
and keeping an eye on any changes that
could
really affect how much you pay or for
how long you pay your loss